Hey everybody! James Cullen Bressack here
and I am s uperd duper excited to be doing
a Masterclass with FilmCourage on the
22nd of this month (North Hollywood Area). We're gonna be
talking about all things horror movies
how to get a horror movie up what little
tricks and things I've learned in making
movies and really I'm just gonna be
answering a ton of questions so I'm
excited to see you all there hope it's a
good night I think it's gonna be awesome!
You know because in the same shot he's
supposed to get sprayed with the blood
James and I wrote both the scripts and
the distributors that you didn't end up
selling the film to I approached and
said hey if I made a film in the same
genre would you buy it and they said yes
and so they pre bought her film alright
guys wardrobe is clear
mix up this later quiet breeze lock it
up
better line when they're walking away
where he's like move your ass and pushes
him into the room for that wait hold up
from them to these guys during that
little exchange then we're going to get
a shot of them here well is walked or
thrilled
Claire can you do that help again the
biggest challenge in a set I constantly
find myself saying and thinking if I
just had like two more days or if I just
had like three more days to film I
wouldn't have to sacrifice stuff because
here I'll show you this is my script and
if you look in it I mean I have my
entire shot list that I check off
everything on whether I do it and
certain things you know you'll see like
there's check marks next to a lot of
stuff and then certain stuff I don't end
up shooting so yeah Borgo like you you
turn and then it's not like a jump turn
and get up to go over okay and actually
I have a lot of prep work I do like all
my notes for they're all color-coded so
you know Blue means visuals
green means wardrobe pink means effects
so I have literally notes for actors
notes for everything throughout the
entire script on every single page pages
and pages and pages of notes and I draw
a little overhead pictures of how I want
to block everybody stuff like this
usually doesn't make sense to anybody
but me but uh it definitely prep work is
is the thing that really really I think
solidifies a movie for me so I mean and
it's also on this short of a schedule
because we have 14 days to shoot the
movie and it's a 95 page script you're
shooting six to ten pages a day which is
pretty intense when I was in Thailand I
had a 28 day shooting schedule so I was
shooting like three to four pages a day
but if you look like you know if if you
write out a bunch of stuff like in here
I have certain things of like this is
how the character feels like she pulls
back in saying something childlike anger
and hate behind her voice but it isn't
loud it's more subdued stuff like that
it gives you more of a moment that
you're a
- just go in on how you already intended
for the scene to go you work with the
actors during the blocking and some of
some of the actors I'm blessed like to
have people like Zack and Tom Green and
Shannen Doherty and and Stephanie s Dez
and everybody who's been involved
they've all put in time before the movie
so I was able to talk with them about
their characters and really go through
all of this so their scripts matched
note wise with my scripts so they
already kind of know what I was going
for originally what was layered in each
character and like each character's
backstory past the page so we developed
that together and then it's kind of
comes into clockwork because with all
the stuff like focus or sound from a
plane you don't have as much time to
really work with the actors so you have
to go in and and you know work with them
prior and really get them to where you
want them before what do you think of
that I just adjusted yes he's gonna look
here Erin's here Claire's here and when
she's over here she's over by the stove
I know how much time my ad tells me how
much time I have left in the scene and I
have to choose between doing another
take or scrapping a shot and I go well
what's more important this angle or that
angle and then I go okay I want the
other takes so let's scrap this shot or
I go let's just move on so I can get
that shot and so it's constantly
deciding like what's the most important
thing for the scene what do I need for
the Edit and so if you look at like my
shot list if I pull up any scene I have
stuff where it's like what I need and
what I want and like a perfect example
is I haven't shot scene three yet and
you'll see I scrapped one two three four
shots on it already before I even did it
and I know because this is the one
location that we are stealing we're not
permitted for where we're shooting we're
running into a cemetery really quick and
getting a couple shots there so I know
I'm only gonna have time for like two or
three shots and I got to get out when I
originally shot lists it is like 10 so
you know it's it's stuff like that you
way things into the balance and then
you'll see over here I'm going through
this whole shot list and I start adding
things on the side and scratching out
other stuff because when the blocking
changes I go well this shot doesn't even
matter so I need that another great
thing is you know you'll go through the
shot list and you're shooting something
and let's say it's a close-up of
somebody talking and then you also have
an insert shot of them picking something
up at the end of the tank I'm just like
pan down and show them picking this
thing up so set for that pick it up and
I put it at the end of the shot that way
I have two shots in one we don't have to
set up for it
so it's it's you know it's just a lot of
thinking on your toes and grabbing as
much stuff as you possibly can so you
know how your films gonna be cut
prioritize in your scenes what you want
versus what you need has always shoot
general coverage of what you need so
that if you have to move on you can
because I see a lot of people always
getting stuck in a scene and they're
like well I need this for the Edit and I
need that for that edit and it's it's a
lot of wants so you choose on your day
you know if you have like the
preliminary schedule for the day like
this right here
you go through and you see all these
scenes now we have a giant scene count
today and a giant amount of pages and
you look at that and you go okay like
let's say like this scene is the most
important right here so that's where I'm
gonna focus my the most of my time or
this one and then the other scenes you
especially when you're fighting against
the clock the other scenes you shoot
generally you know you do something cool
but style is sometimes a luxury on these
shoots so you don't have to make every
single scene in a stylistic masterpiece
you just have to make it competently
shot and then you go in and finesse it
later the garnish is what you what you
save for later if you if you
at the time one of my favorite things
about doing a scene like this especially
in like this location that we have over
here is I originally had like 14 shots
shot listed for this scene a bunch of
stuff prepped and then when we were
doing the walkthrough I saw this this
part of the hospital on this location
and it looked really awesome and I knew
it was gonna look good on camera and the
lights but since it's such a tight space
I chose this location which totally made
my shot let's go completely out the door
because now I can't do any of the things
I originally planned because it's such a
tight space and so many people so now
we're kind of like winging it a little
so it's a it's kind of fun because it
keeps you on your toes and it's it's
very different because you know I'm very
prepared all the time this is one of the
first times where I kind of just have to
make make things up as I go which is
we'll see how it goes and I talked with
my DP a lot I created a Dropbox I'll
pull it up I go like you know lighting
and mood so these are certain like I
wanted practical lights throughout the
house so I took pictures of that I'd
paintings that had hold on pictures that
have the moon we'll have like shots from
other movies so these have like
definitely the same kind of lighting
that I wanted for the aesthetic look of
the film and so you go through and you
look at how this is lit and you see like
all that stuff and then now I'll pull up
a shot from my actual movie and you'll
see how we matched it so
and this is what we ended up with this
is still from from monitor on
color-corrected so it's all about having
having that dialogue in that
conversation and you know for me it's
really important to have everybody on
the same page so they all understand the
vision so I always you know that's just
my cinematography file I also have you
know an art file effects file a hair
file a makeup file a wardrobe file and
all that stuff and everybody all the
department heads put their stuff into it
and I put my stuff into it and we
combine and work it out and it looks
like Markus is pulling me now
one of the things that I've really
played with the most on this film that
I'm really excited about is is my scene
to scene transitions like every single
time in the movie there's there's almost
every scene we go into a scene to see
the transition so it's like you know
I'll have a character pick up a coffee
mug and then they'll go to sip it and
we'll cut into a close-up of them
sipping it and when they pull it away
from their mouth we pull back and we're
in a different scene so it's just them
sipping the same coffee mugs but they're
on a different day and a different scene
so finding different moments to have
something that similar art-wise so
you're on that focused on it and then
you're somewhere else I like to hide how
we got from one place to another and I
think it definitely helps with the
fluidity of the movie and also with the
fluidity of the character because a lot
of this movie plays as some cerebral
thing within the characters psyche
almost as if it's the the lead actresses
psyche so it's almost as if like the
entire movie is a quilt woven together
so I don't want stuff to people to ever
know when something ended and once
something begins and we go in and out of
flashbacks a lot so one of the cool
things about that is instead of having
the flashbacks be separate scenes
I'll have the character turn and look
and we dolly over there and we have a
dramatic lighting shift and it plays as
if it's a little play in front of her
and then they leave the room and so
there's these really cool transitions
that that play out and like the world
changes lights come on art moves and I
got a lot of that from watching the
movie Lone Star if you've seen that so
we've been kind of copying that a little
but you know doing my own version of it
but watching it I was like I have to do
that kind of thing that was awesome
and so I played it both ways which way
you wanted here um I think this side
this side but also at the same time
since since your character's supposed to
be it doesn't matter
nothing what all right I just wanted to
make yeah for you for you specifically
because I can be looking up here yeah
approaching a distributor in advance is
something that really helps especially
for this film what I did is I had my
movie pernicious which is coming out in
theaters soon that all the distributors
saw when I was playing festivals and
they made bids on it and the
distributors that we didn't end up
selling the film to I approached and
said hey you know they put in an offer
for it and I said hey if I made a film
in the same genre would you buy it and
they said yes and so they pre bought the
film and so these films were pre-sold
before they were made it was very easy
to finance them based off of they were
already sold before they were made so
it's like hey one once the film is
delivered you get X amount of dollars
from the distributor it's very easy to
say hey can you finance this because I'm
literally basically borrowing money from
you for like a little bit of time and
then it comes in they basically said as
long as I'm writing and directing which
on one and I swung it as a tube film
deal that I would write both with his AK
exact with direct one and I would direct
one and then they said that it had to be
like ghost house types so like you know
genre films with a supernatural element
that's that's what's big right now for
for genre alright